نحن في الجولان المحتل حيث يسود تاهب
اسرائيلي عسكري جوا وبرا ايضا بعد ان كانت
اسرائيل اسقطت مسيره ايرانيه فوق الجليل
كانت انطلقت من الاراضي السوريه وذلك اعقب
ايضا غارات اسرائيليه متكرره طال اخرها
مطار الضبعه قربه حمص حيث مخازن للمسيرات
الايرانيه التابعه لحزب الله هناك والتي
يعتقد بانها كانت غارات جاءت ردا على
عمليه مجدو التي اتهمت فيها اسرائيل حزب
الله الاجواء تبقى متوتره للغايه على
الجبهه الشماليه المرجح ان تكون هناك
المزيد من الغارات الاسرائيليه في العمق
السوري وتخشى اسرائيل ايضا من ردود محتمله
خاصه بسلاح المسيرات
وهنا ايضا على حدود لبنان تسود حاله تاهب
منذ عمليه ماجدو الاخيره التي حاولت
اسرائيل ان ترد عليها في الجغرافيا
السوريه وتدعي اسرائيل بان حزب الله عاد
نشر قواته في المنطقه الحدوديه على النحو
الذي سبق حرب تموز عام 2006 وبين هذا وذاك
يرى مراقبون بان كل الاطراف تنفذ هجمات
بدون ان تتبنى ايا منها بهدف خلق معادله
ردع تمنع الجانب الاخر من الرد او الهجوم
زياد حلبي العربيه الحدود اللبنانيه